[Música]
condenan a 18 años de prisión al líder
del grupo ultraderechista outkeepers
fallado culpable de Conspiración
sediciosa por el ataque al Capitolio de
Estados Unidos del 6 de enero de 2021 y
es la primera sentencia que se conoce
por el caso
amnistía internacional sostiene que la
policía y el ejército de Perú les
dispararon a los manifestantes en las
protestas antigubernamentales y le pidió
a la fiscalía investigar en su informe
habla incluso de racismo que legitimó la
muerte de 49 personas
Rusia pacta y empieza el despliegue de
armas nucleares tácticas en velarus el
presidente de este país dijo que las
primeras ojivas ya estaban en movimiento
de otro lado los combatientes del grupo
Wagner comienzan su retiro de territorio
ucraniano para ser reemplazados por
soldados rusos
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados Unidos
ser líder del grupo ultraderechista
outkeepers fue condenado a 18 años de
cárcel por los delitos de rebelión y
sedición Stuart roads fue calificado por
el juez que llevó el caso como una
amenaza para Estados Unidos su equipo
legal dijo que apelaría la decisión se
espera que su condena siente un
precedente y que vengan otros castigos
severos para los involucrados en el
asalto del Capitolio de Estados Unidos
Manuela Cano con los detalles
se trata de la sentencia más larga
derivada de la toma del Capitolio de
Estados Unidos en enero de 2021
Steward Road fundador del grupo de
extrema derecha o keepers deberá pasar
18 años en prisión anticipamos mucho más
que una sentencia de 18 años no es que
esté de acuerdo con la sentencia pero
anticipé mucho más Road fue condenado
por orquestar un complot que buscaba
mantener al presidente Joe biden fuera
de la Casa Blanca tras las elecciones de
2020 el militante fue encontrado
culpable por rebelión y conspiración
sediciosa siendo el primero en ser
sentenciado por ese delito además el
juez acordó aplicar penas agravantes Por
terrorismo algo inédito para los
involucrados en el asalto del Capitolio
su equipo legal aseguró que apelará la
decisión
creemos que tenemos una buena apelación
en camino esperamos con interés la
apelación el proceso de apelación y
apoyamos firmemente a Stuart Rose no
creemos que sea una amenaza para la
sociedad creemos en absoluto
en la audiencia El juez lo catalogó como
un peligro para Estados Unidos y también
para la democracia el acusado por su
parte dijo sin pruebas que era un preso
político roads tiene 58 años nació en
Texas y se licenció de la facultad de
derecho de jeyle fue paracaidista del
ejército comenzó su carrera en la Corte
Suprema de Arizona una que dejó para
fundar a los keepers hace más de 10 años
ahora la condena de roads marca un hito
en la investigación sobre el asalto del
Capitolio una decisión que podría abrir
el camino a sentencias más severas en el
hecho que marcó la historia democrática
de Estados Unidos en otras noticias de
Estados Unidos mientras se calienta la
campaña por la nominación republicana se
enfría la relación entre dos antiguos
aliados el expresidente Donald Trump y
el gobernador de Florida ron de santis
quienes han intensificado los ataques
entre sí desde que este último anunciara
oficialmente sus aspiraciones
presidenciales ambos buscan ser
candidato del partido que competirá
contra biden en las presidenciales esta
vez Trump criticó la gestión de desantis
en el llamado estado del sol
cuando salgan a la luz los hechos de ron
de santimonios verán que es mejor que la
mayoría de los gobernadores demócratas
pero en el mejor de los casos es muy
regular en comparación con los
gobernadores republicanos que han hecho
un trabajo fantástico y mira a Disney y
que lío es podría haber llegado a un
acuerdo fácil pero no quería mostrarle a
las noticias falsas lo duro que es todo
el asunto de Disney Es realmente muy
desafortunado ahora se están eliminando
miles y miles de puestos de trabajo y
mucha gente está muy molesta por eso
y también en Estados Unidos continúan
los partes de tranquilidad entre la casa
blanca y los republicanos en el congreso
sobre las negociaciones para Elevar el
techo de la deuda Esta vez fue el
presidente Joe biden quien reiteró que
las conversaciones con el líder de la
cámara de representantes habían sido
productivas por su parte mccarthy
mencionó que pese a que por el momento
no se ha llegado a ningún acuerdo Los
negociadores continuaban trabajando sin
embargo el tiempo se agota Y antes del
primero de junio deberían llegar a un
consenso para evitar un posible impacto
y hemos tenido varias conversaciones
productivas y de hecho nuestro personal
continúa reuniéndose mientras hablamos y
están progresando dejó en claro una y
otra vez que el incumplimiento de pago
de nuestra deuda nacional no es una
opción el pueblo estadounidense merece
saber que los pagos del seguro social
estarán allí que el hospital de
veteranos permanecerá abierto y que se
lograrán Progreso económico y lo
Seguiremos logrando el defaul pone todo
eso en riesgo los líderes del Congreso
entienden eso y todos han acordado que
no habrá incumplimiento es hora de que
el congreso actúe ahora
amnistía internacional publicó su
informe sobre lo que ocurrió en las
protestas antigubernamentales que hubo
en Perú después de la destitución del
presidente Pedro Castillo el 7 de
diciembre concluyeron que la policía y
el ejército le disparó a los
manifestantes incluso con armas
prohibidas y agregaron que el gobierno
de Dina boluarte descalificó a los
habitantes del departamento de puno con
frases racistas que legitimaron las
muertes eumar esa nos cuenta más
racismo letal Ese es el nombre del
informe presentado por amnistía
internacional en el que se denuncia uso
ilegítimo de la fuerza y ejecuciones
extrajudiciales durante el control de
las protestas que sacudieron al país
tras la destitución de Pedro Castillo
una respuesta con sesgo racial que
habría sido coordinada y tolerada desde
el estado y no casos aislados No
encontramos evidencia que ninguna de las
personas que fueron sometidas a
ejecuciones extrajudiciales o asesinatos
arbitrarios estaban empleando la
violencia en el momento que se utilizó
la fuerza letal en su contra amnistía
estudió en su informe 49 muertes se
manifestantes ocurridas en choques con
fuerzas del orden la mayoría de ellas en
el sur del país lo que permitió detectar
un patrón de estigmatización en contra
de poblaciones históricamente
discriminadas así como el empleo de ese
instancias de poder de un discurso de
odio nosotros
definitivamente nos gustaría
a los fiscales y a la fiscal de la
nación que investiguen si es que el
discurso por la presidenta y de otros
están en el marco del Artículo 20 de la
gobernanza internacional para lo que son
derechos civiles el informe se suma el
pronunciamiento de la semana pasada del
relator especial de Naciones Unidas para
la libre asociación que se declaró
alarmado por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza que causó más de 60 muertes
durante las protestas se espera que la
fiscalía tome declaración a la
presidenta Dina boluarte la próxima
semana sobre lo ocurrido durante las
manifestaciones
los habitantes del suroccidente de
Colombia completa más de cinco días sin
el servicio de gas natural debido al
cierre preventivo de un tubo
transportador el Ministerio de minas y
energía aseguró que el servicio se
empezará a restablecer de manera
progresiva durante esta noche mientras
que muchos buscaron alternativas para no
tener tantas afectaciones Andrés triviño
tiene todos los detalles
volvieran los hornos de leña al
suroccidente de Colombia al mismo tiempo
que aumentaron las compras de cocinas
eléctricas alrededor de 6 millones de
personas se han visto afectadas por la
suspensión temporal de gas natural que
ya completa varios días debido a una
anomalía geológica la industria
alimentaria y los hogares buscan
alternativas
nos está afectando la falta del gas
Porque esa es una cosa que la
necesitamos sea como sea la estamos
necesitando y ahora Estamos es cocinando
ya con leña porque qué podemos hacer
no hay nada más que hacer si no
conseguir leña no hay gas y además
tampoco no hay ni plata para comprar
ni ni gas ni comprar en leña carbón
habitantes de los departamentos de
caldas risaralda Quindío nariño cauca y
Valle del cauca han reportado la
suspensión del servicio el pasado 20 de
mayo la empresa de occidente reportó Un
aumento en la temperatura del subsuelo
cercano a un volcán asegurando que se
trataría de un incendio subterráneo con
un termómetro superior a los 600 grados
la empresa decidió suspender el
suministro de manera preventiva ya que
uno de los tubos transportadores se
extiende por esta zona un mercado que
representa el 26% de usuarios de gas
licuado de petróleo de todo el país la
ministra de minas y energía visitó la
zona junto con expertos dando un parte
de tranquilidad y asegurando que el
servicio será restablecido pronto y de
manera gradual vamos con noticias
relacionadas con la guerra en Ucrania al
presidente de velarus Alexander
lukashenko anunció que ya empezó a
desplegar las armas nucleares tácticas
en territorio bielorruso un movimiento
que materializa lo que ya anunció en
marzo el presidente Vladimir Putin según
la agencia Tas el ministro de defensa de
Rusia
aseguró que la decisión se ha tomado
como respuesta a la escalada de las
amenazas en sus fronteras
y tras asegurar que tienen el control
total de bahamut este jueves el grupo
Wagner empezó a entregar el ejército
regular de Moscú sus posiciones en la
ciudad donde Mercenario rusos y el
ejército ucraniano han estado
combatiendo durante meses en la batalla
más larga de esta guerra continúa
desmintiendo La derrota más detalles con
lluís Muñoz
el grupo Wagner inició su repliegue de
bahamut tras el anuncio de la captura de
la ciudad la semana pasada Los
mercenarios van a dejar su espacio al
propio ejército ruso así se lo comunicó
a sus tropas el líder y fundador del
grupo Jeff y pregosin
Qué pasa muchachos Eso es todo nos
mudamos en 10 15 minutos todos se van
antes del primero de junio descansaremos
nos prepararemos y luego obtendremos una
nueva tarea
se espera que está retirada termine
antes de fin de
mayorigosin muy crítico con Los Altos
funcionarios de defensa de Rusia ha
dicho que estarán listos para regresar
si el ejército no puede controlar la
situación
Estos son beaver idolic en el momento en
el que el ejército tenga un momento
difícil ellos se plantarán y bloquearán
el paso al ejército ucraniano desde
Ucrania lo ven como un reagrupamiento
por las bajas que han provocado al grupo
Wagner durante meses la viceministra de
defensa ucraniana reconoció en Telegram
el intercambio de tropas con Rusia en
las afueras de enemigo ha reemplazado
las unidades de Wagner con fuerzas del
ejército regular dentro de la ciudad
misma combatientes de Wagner
ha sido la batalla más larga y
Sangrienta de la guerra Wagner reconoció
más de 20.000 bajas mientras Ucrania
está a la espera de realizar una
contraofensiva en la que pueda recuperar
un enclave simbólico Aunque convertido
en escombros
España irá a elecciones municipales este
domingo 28 de mayo una de las
principales barreras es vencer la
abstención que en los comicios de 2019
superó El 36% junto con los votos en
blanco y los nulos ante la baja
participación surgieron alternativas de
la sociedad civil para hacer de la
política algo más representativo
conozcamos algunas de estas opciones en
Madrid con el informe de nuestra
corresponsal Marina Colorado
son las 9 de la mañana e Iván está en su
tercera entrenamiento del día este
atleta de élite y entrenador ahora
además es candidato a concejal de
deportes para la alcaldía de Madrid yo
creo que nos iría bastante mejor si en
todas las áreas en todas las
competencias del ayuntamiento de Madrid
tuviéramos un político menos y un
profesional más el 28 de mayo hay
elecciones municipales y regionales en
España en la capital por primera vez una
iniciativa ciudadana Presenta una opción
para llenar la alcaldía de ciudadanos
expertos en temas concretos y no de
políticos Cuando entras en un partido
político empiezas a escalar y bueno al
final te tienen que colocar en una de
las competencias Pero tú seguramente no
sepas de esa competencia en este caso al
no ser políticos a ser profesionales
desde hace muchísimo tiempo en esas
competencias sí que sabemos de lo que
vamos a hablar Buenos días En este acto
de campaña está annelimatos de República
Dominicana y tercera en la lista de
recupera Madrid con otros 57
profesionales insiste en la importancia
de que los migrantes se involucren en la
vida pública y que los que puedan voten
en las municipales es importante que
salgamos que estemos que nos empapemos
de la ciudad en la que vivimos porque
nosotros vivimos aquí trabajamos aquí y
por lo tanto tenemos mucho que aportar a
esta ciudad en 2019 más del 35% del
electorado en Madrid no fue a las urnas
esta realidad es la que quiere reflejar
el partido escaños en blanco que
pretende captar a los electores que
votan nulo en blanco o se abstienen pero
lo que hacemos Es en caso de salir
elegidos no Juramos el cargo Entonces
ese escaño se queda vacío esta
candidatura renuncia también a
subvenciones dietas o sueldos por lo que
queremos es que se vea si hay algún tipo
de problema Y a partir de ahí se abre un
debate sobre Qué es cuál es el problema
que hay alternativas viables Aunque
minoritarias en una ciudad que en las
últimas tres décadas y media ha tenido
30 años de alcaldías de derecha o centro
derecha
y cerramos en Sierra Leona a una fuerte
tormenta se llevó consigo el que una vez
fue el símbolo más importante del país
el famoso árbol de algodón que se
elevaba sobre la capital se cayó durante
las horas de la noche dejando solo parte
de un tronco afilado se dice que en 1700
cuando esclavos estadounidenses
liberados llegaron para fundar el país
se reunían bajo sus ramas para ofrecer
oraciones antes de mudarse a su Nuevo
Hogar
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
Gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]